- What the f- is this?
Like why would you ever do this?
(energetic music)
- Oh gosh.
- Hey.
- What is this?
- Why does this exist?
- (laughs)
- Why is there a marshmallow on the end?
- Are marshmallows supposed
to go with hot dogs?
- Is this how she served it?
Is this what it looked like?
- Oh, well what is it
supposed to look like?
- So this is inspired by Filipino food.
- I'm gonna eat it just for the sake
of not having to look at it.
- Rule number one,
everything needs to be
aesthetically pleasing.
- All right, you want me to eat this?
- Do I eat, just like
the whole marshmallow
and a little bit?
- It's got to be marshmallow first.
- See, I feel like I need to
divide this marshmallow up.
Okay, that looks better, right?
- I guess I'll try it.
I'll eat the marshmallow
and the sausage together.
- Oh my god, it's so nasty.
- No, it's so bad!
- I grabbed the whole marshmallow
in my mouth (mumbles).
- It tastes like a hot
dog with sugar on it.
- That's not a good food combination.
Who the fuck thought of this?
- I actually kind of like it.
Savory and sweet.
It's actually pretty good.
- It's not the worst thing ever.
Almost like if a hot dog
bun were like really sugary.
It's way more offensive
to look at than to eat.
- This does not scream
"rich" by any means.
- Maybe if her kid, like, loves this
and they like went to the Philippines
and they had this.
- "Oh my gosh, this is
the best thing ever.
"Mom, make this for me on my birthday."
- I probably would eat this.
I would eat anything as a kid.
- It did save me going out to lunch,
which I was about to do.
Marshmallow and hot dogs. (laughs)
(energetic music)
- Tastes like a hot dog and marshmallow.
Maybe kids would actually like it, though.
Like what's not to like when
you're like seven years old?
A hot dog, marshmallow?
- Who did this? Ivanka Trump?
What compelled her to be like,
"Yeah, we should just multitask."
What, are you gonna put the whole thing
in your mouth at once?
Listen, that's tripe (mumbles).
(energetic music)